aujourd'hui en URSS vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir qu'il existe des camps de
concentration comment pouvez-vous serrer
la main de ces gens là
quand vous surnomme bigoudis à cause de
votre calvitie qu'on imite vos
imitations ou alors que Stéphane Collaro
vous transforme en crabe rien de tout
cela ne mérite rien ne vous agace rien
du tout pour réagissez bien
je le trouve plus ou moins réussi c'est
surtout le public qui doit réagir je
suis le plus mal placé pour avoir une
opinion mais ça ne mérite pourquoi
voulez-vous que ça mérite
chez Collaro vous vous trouvez comment
j'ai compris il a voulu présenter un
prolo un métallo parien type il m'a même
mis un mégot alors je vais me fume pas
ça n'a pas d'importance et puis c'est
tout pour le reste c'est son affaire lui
et le public vous connaissiez ce
surnomez
comme ça vous avez vu la une du Matin de
Paris la semaine dernière où on parlait
du look de la CGT alors quand on lisait
l'article on s'apercevait que c'était
juste une manchette de journalistes mais
est-ce que vous croyez pas que le que le
look
crazyki c'est-à-dire le côté un peu
voyeur comme ça la casquette est-ce
qu'on voyait pas que ça peut décourager
certaines professions de des cadres des
professeurs de s'engager de de militer à
la CGT ce que vous croyez pas vous
donner à la CGT finalement un look un
peu trop polo quoi
je pense pas donner plus spécialement à
look prolo quoi je suis comme je suis
ensuite la CGT ça ne sera même pas à une
personne ni à ni à son allure on a la
tête qu'on a et non il y a l'image qu'on
fabrique et puis il y a la réalité des
personnes et de l'organisation vous me
parliez de du Matin de Paris c'était un
titre incorrect une correspondait pas
vrai finalement oui mais ça n'était pas
innocent et c'est le nom c'est pas une
affaire de justice j'ai réagi en
protestant et le Matin de Paris a pas
publié ma protestation
je tiens à me faire respecter et à faire
respecter l'organisation que je
représente le vaporant revenir à votre
question ce sont de la diversité des
salariés je me sens représentatif du
monde du travail tel qu'il est d'accord
tu
j'ai souvent l'occasion de rencontrer
des ingénieurs des cadres supérieurs des
techniciens bien sûr des scientifiques
je visite je discute nous ne comprenons
et ils n'ont pas l'impression de parler
à un extraterrestre je vous arrête tous
ces phrases
je vais essayer de me convaincre de
rentrer à la CGT
vous avez trois minutes
comme dites-vous
vous êtes une salarié
il vous arrive où il peut vous arriver
d'avoir besoin de défendre vos intérêts
deux salariés
ça a l'air avancement sécurité de
l'emploi dignité aussi vous avez besoin
d'être organisé toute seule il peut vous
arriver de vous débrouiller l'important
c'est syndicats mais pourquoi la saison
là j'y viens mais d'abord d'abord l'idée
c'est de se grouper alors pourquoi la
CGT mais parce que
citez-moi un syndicat plus combatif que
la CGT
plus proche des préoccupations des gens
plus ferme dans les discussions avec les
patrons elle a toutes sortes elle a
toutes sortes de défauts mais en tout
cas
essayez et si même si même il ne vous
convient pas et bien contribuer à le
faire comme vous voudriez qu'il soit il
ne restez pas seul parce que comme
salarié vous êtes en fait est-ce que tu
vas manger
si vous commencez à faire engager mes
salariés à la saison
moi je veux seulement quand on me pose
cette question là je me demandais une
augmentation demain matin
c'est possible alors maintenant
je ne cherche pas comme ça à convaincre
elle est un peu je veux donner à
réfléchir alors écoutez vous faites
partie des gens qui pensaient que le
bilan des pays de l'Est et globalement
positif
vous avez participé en septembre 86 à
Berlin est une réunion de la FSM vous
êtes un peu réconcilié avec eux vous
rencontrer le 11e c'est un peu
réconcilié avec eux et vous vous êtes
maintenant à des vice-président de la
FSM en compagnie de roumain de Bulgares
de tchèque de Russes et d'allemand de
l'Est alors gros cul de beaucoup
d'autres de tous les continents
est-ce que vous Henri Kazuki aujourd'hui
vous vivriez dans un pays de l'est
d'abord je suis français oui bon alors
moi j'aime bien vivre en vie d'accord
surtout alors parce que ce genre de
question vous voyez ça n'a pas beaucoup
de sens
moi je vis en France et je par contre
j'ai une certaine idée de comment on
pourrait vivre mieux en France mais
votre idée de vivre mieux en France
c'est un peu se rapprocher des pays de
l'est quand même pas du tout
pas au sens de copier ce qui se fait
dans tel ou théorie
il y a certaines choses qui
m'intéressent certaines choses
m'intéressent certaines choses dans le
caractère fondamental par exemple je
trouve qu'il y a des injustices et des
inégalités sociales dans notre système
évidemment
je considère que tel qu'il est cette
société a besoin d'être changé mais à la
française disons qu'en fonction de notre
histoire de la manière de vivre des
Français etc tout à fait autre chose
bien mais mais vous ne me ferez pas sous
prétexte il y a tel ou tels nous faire
changer d'avis qui était l'hôtel défaut
renoncer à comprendre ce qui se passe
d'importance dans ces pays-là ce qui s'y
est passé là pendant si je prends
l'Union soviétique par exemple
ce qu'elle a fait il y a 70 ans c'est
l'équivalent à notre siècle de ce que la
Révolution française a fait il y a deux
siècles oui une question définitive ça
sera la dernière et j'aimerais qu'on
rebondier le plus franchement possible
vous avez eu le malheur pendant la
guerre des déporté
aujourd'hui en URSS vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir qu'il existe des camps de
concentration comment pouvez-vous serrer
la main de ces gens-là vous savez qu'on
URSS les Juifs n'ont pas le droit de
sortir du RSS comment pouvez-vous serrer
la main de ces gens-là comment
pouvez-vous me poser des questions c'est
un journaliste aussi peut
raisonnable parce que non aujourd'hui ça
existait mais aujourd'hui en URSS il n'y
a pas que ça n'existe pas aujourd'hui
non aujourd'hui il y a parce que ils
n'ont pas ils ont peu de prison ils ont
un système pénitentiaire qui est basé
sur des camps de travail ils disent que
c'est pour une rééducation mais ça
concerne les gens des prisonniers droits
communs ils n'ont pas de prisonniers
politiques il y en a eu nous avons il y
en a une nous avons protesté
s'il en reste quelques-uns ils sont en
train de régler cette question et vous
le savez les réformes qui ont lieu en
Union soviétique en ce moment notamment
sur la question des droits de l'homme y
compris sur la liberté population les
juifs ou de tout autre sont des choses
qu'on appelle les refuges qui n'ont pas
le droit de sortir justement je suis en
train de vous dire cette question qui
nous a amené à critiquer à discuter
alors dire mais pour pourquoi vous
laissez pas ces gens circuler sortir etc
aujourd'hui c'est en cours de règlement
vous pensez qu'ils ont entendu pas
seulement je pense pas que c'est parce
que seulement nous avons donné notre
avis nous avons joué un rôle et
utile justement
à une époque où nous reprochait de ne de
ne pas crier nous avons dit qu'il
fallait publiquement quand c'était
nécessaire
train de changer sérieusement et
personne le conteste dans les milieux de
l'information je crois en général vous
me surprenez par votre question parce
que c'est la vie vos collègues en ce
moment sont en train de devenir prudents
et pour être sûr de rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu